Y'all, so many people asked about my head scarf,
and I love it because it's actually from a small shop on Etsy.
And this is gonna be just like when the girlies are like.
It has pockets, but
it's a Jersey turban headband,
so it takes all the work out of wrapping your own hair.
Gonna try and do it here,
but I don't have one of those little card clippy things.
Put it on like you would like
when you put on a little toddler turban hair thing for.
For a baby.
This color I got custom.
I did a custom order because,
you know, your girl likes pink,
but she has so many options on the website.
I'm gonna show you her site now.
This is her Etsy shop.
She's based out of Germany.
It's called jazzefine.
She has so many different options.
Here's the pink one.
She added it to her listing.
I have a couple of these.
The strawberry hat that I wore to Charleston. Wine and food.
This is completely unsponsored.
I just like to share where I get cool shit.
So go get yourself one. So cute.